le gouvernement veut la supprimer dès
2022 la redevance télé mais au fait
c'est quoi exactement cette redevance
vous savez à quoi ça sert
pour les personnes âgées non ok on
reprend la redevance télé ou
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
comme vous voulez existe depuis 1949 le
principe est simple chaque français
détenteur d'un poste de télé la paix est
d'accord là dessus en gros c'est un
pauvre vise à financer une partie du
budget de la télé publique d'abord la
rtf plus le rtf les rentrées sont très
simple vous savez les rentrées c'est ce
que à 90% ou 95% même ceux que paie à
l'office les auditeurs et
téléspectateurs
autrement dit l'essentiel de nos
ressources
cette la redevance
1975 le rtf éclater cette société-là
remplace bon tf1 antenne 2 ou encore
line à la redevance télé continue de
financer une partie de leur budget onze
ans plus tard en 1986 tf1 devient privé
donc financé par la publicité et non
plus par la redevance résultat la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
diminue elle devrait s'élever à 500 6
francs au lieu de 541 pour la couleur la
redevance rapportera ainsi 6,2 milliards
de francs c'est moins qu'en 1986 depuis
sa création la redevance télé se
retrouvent souvent au coeur des débats
des politiques de l'augmenter d'autres
la supprimer voir la remplacer
la remplacer comme en 2000 un rapport
parlementaire juge cette taxe trop
archaïque injuste et coûteuse je mettre
à la place
une taxe sur les jeux selon ce député
nous ne proposons pas un impôt
supplémentaire nous proposons d'affecter
une autre recette de l'état qui soit
équivalente et qui souhaitent également
affectés au soutien du service public
audiovisuel
aucune suite n'est donnée à ce rapport à
partir de 2005 petit changement pour les
contribuables la redevance est adossé à
la taxe d'habitation le but piéger les
fraudeurs c'est un impôt qui est mal
perçu donc nous nous sommes dit avec
nicolas sarkozy que chaque personne qui
est locataire ou propriétaire d'un
appartement ou d'une maison on peut
penser sauf c'est nous dit le contraire
qu'elle a un téléviseur dans cette
maison dans cet appartement en 2021 23
millions de foyers étaient assujettis à
la redevance son coup 138 euros par an
pour la métropole 88 pour l'outre-mer
[Musique]